je suis une personne très curieuse
ahouilleuse ou curieux arrête
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure façon la meilleure façon
sécurité on a une folle ça fait une
heure de lit
[Applaudissements]
je veux vérifier un truc
toi je vais juste vérifier un truc
remets-le
[Applaudissements]
il y a une autre façon il y a une autre
façon donc c'est pas un jeu arrête
d'appuyer sur les boutons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci alors voilà
d'abord Alexandre il y a un bouton là ce
qui veut arrêter ça y est j'ai trouvé
[Rires]
pour Noël une seule idée de cadeau
Salomé des bailleurs absolument
volontiers volontiers
on vous a surnommé Salomé vous êtes né à
Bahia donc vous êtes Salomé de Bayard
ce qu'on peut raconter en revanche c'est
que quand vous étiez si quand vous étiez
petit de votre père a adopter un petit
garçon aveugle qui jouait de l'accordéon
qui jouait de l'accordéon et vous avez
appris à chanter avec lui
non mais arrête faut pas faire attention
allez remets une chanson
aveugle jouer de l'accordéon et vous
avez appris à chanter en l'écoutant chez
moi et puis vous avez chanté des choses
qu'on appelle les fenêtres c'est quand
on chante quand on chante sous les
fenêtres comme ça
[Musique]
vous avez commencé à chanter on peut
dire en quelle année vous avez commencé
à chanter professionnellement
du Brésil ça l'année de retour des
général aux affaires
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
n'a jamais pensé en fait à faire autre
chose que chanter toute votre vie vous
n'avez été habité que par l'idée de
chanter vous avez même pas pensé à
trouver un mec riche
non j'ai pensé seulement à être heureuse
ta maman en ce moment et ça c'est de la
merde
[Musique]
j'ai pas perdu de plus Malabar je dois
perdre la raison
alors le premier personne à joli
première visite en France en 676
parce que moi je suis une personne très
curieuse couilleuse ou curieux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
excuse-moi là où vous êtes cultes c'est
qu'en 99 vous avez commencé à bosser
avec Bob Sinclar j'ai 46 ans de
profession
ils sont là ils tombent pas ils ont pas
ils sont pas mal hein non ils sont pas
mal d'origine
c'est pas d'origine
c'est ça que j'aime bien lui je le vois
mais
parfois il est très méchant vous avez
préparé un disque de standard brésilien
qui va sortir quand moi j'attends ça
merci beaucoup
il y a Copacabana
sur le disque que vous préparez
[Musique]
enregistrer et j'étais en studio hier
j'ai enregistré un chanson de les années
50 que Sophia Loren chantait dans un
film Mambo Baka
lalalala
et mettez un pouce bleu